[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings 8 30 now
dancing in the moonlight that's former
astronaut scott kelly performing a space
walk back in 2015.
kelly had been a record holder for total
days in space and also longest american
spaceflight spent more than a year
straight on the international space
station
and now he's out with a new book to
inspire inspire others to dream big the
book is called ready for launch an
astronaut's lesson for success on earth
first on cbs morning scott kelly joins
us now scott good morning to you not
lesson lessons plural there's a lot in
this book i think the big mystery out
off the top is and gail and i were both
arguing over this quote like she wants
to quote it as well
as a kid your own grandmother evaluating
your talents referred to you as and this
is a quote dumb
how did you go from dumb in the eyes of
grandma to nasa astronaut grandma who
was tutoring you by the way and said
look he's helpless i can't teach him to
read he's dumb yeah so grandmother you
know sometimes tough love i think can be
helpful and you know hearing that from
my grandma mother was clearly a wake up
having said that it didn't inspire me to
become a better student and it wasn't
until i was in college
struggling that i was able to find my
own personal inspiration you found a
book the right stuff you were inspired
by by that book
what did you learn about the importance
of failure on your journey from not so
hot to pretty hot stuff you know i think
failure is one of the most important
lessons we can have in life it it shows
us what we need to do to correct our
course uh to be successful i think that
people you know that aren't willing to
fail that aren't willing to take risks
that aren't willing to make mistakes
don't always see what they're really
capable of achieving they never maybe
never real
realize their goals because they're too
scared of taking that risk you also say
it's better to fail at the extraordinary
than to succeed at the ordinary i love
that yeah absolutely because i think it
shows that you're not you know you're
not striving to go further not
challenging yourself enough not seeing
where you really stand in my case i uh
you know the first time i ever tried to
land an f-14
tomcat on an aircraft carrier i failed
and you know i had the option survived
yeah and i did and i had the option of
going to fly an easier airplane but i
thought you know if i'm going to fail at
something i might as well fail at
something i think i can't achieve rather
than something that's easier at least
then i'll know exactly where i stand and
what i'm capable of even the officer at
the time said are you sure this is for
you is this what you want to do but you
said use fear you also say you should
use fear in your favor too most people
do not want to be scared about anything
and you say embrace that yeah i think
it's part of life i mean we are humans
we are you know if we didn't have fear
we wouldn't
exist i mean it's a normal human emotion
i think it's okay you know at times to
be scared i think it you know focus in
focus is in your
your attention on what's important
you know i love the chapter on
leadership and you talk about your
experiences in navy rotc i was in army
rotc and some of the lessons of
leadership i learned at fort bragg north
carolina you talk about assessing
everybody that you're tasked to lead
individually and not having some sort of
big overall arching principle when it
comes to leadership yeah i think it's
important not to like choose hey i'm
going to be this kind of leader for
everybody because you know what i've
learned uh in my different roles as a
leader whether it's you know the
commander of the space shuttle the space
station is that we are all different
we're all motivated in different ways
we're uh so the leadership style has to
be
you know tailored to certain people i
mean some people take very well to like
the servant type leader you know what is
that explain that that's a really
interesting concept the servant type
leader is someone that helps you
do your job what do you need to do your
job to be the best you know employee
that you can to do to perform at you
know your highest level and then there's
you know there's different styles just
based on you know based on your team and
who you're trying to guide and lead yeah
i mean part of what's special about the
book is even though i think it's great
for middle school high school kids even
college-aged kids it's great for adults
as well right i mean like fear also you
continue to manage throughout your life
uh your first spacewalk was something
you would overcome fear uh even though
by then you were an incredibly
accomplished individual uh and i love
the line in the book people always say
failure is not an option no no for scott
kelly failure is always
it was kind of my thing when i was
younger right
all right scott thank you very much for
being here we really appreciate it
best-selling author former astronaut
scott kelly the book is ready for launch
it is on sale now wherever you like to
buy your books come